et
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'amène en pays un petit
séjour comme ça pour le plaisir
pour le plaisir je veux pas tergiversé
je suis là parce que qu'on recherche le
père de la loupe
j'ai fait des calculs thion lolo est né
le 5 août 1999
oui il y a cinq clients potentiels aux
affaires scolaires
voilà des sorties ensemble une petite
amourette d'écoliers c'est ça vous fait
que physique
cet essai clinique alors je les présente
pascal morand hockey pas bête on n'a pas
un crime
ça veut dire normal rien du tout je te
le dis toujours
or l'impact sur la fille de 61 cents
au qatar tests
dire tu as soon as j'étais presque un
club arrive pas à pardonner le scandale
après scandale
trop collante et de scandales la seule
chose positive que j'ai retiré de toutes
sortes ça m'a permis retiré 10 1
[Musique]
ce
qui va comme j'étais amoureuse de toi
[Musique]
un petit peu dur avec elle ça fait 15
ans elle n'a pas changé ça se voit tout
de suite
tout avait toujours chez tes parents ça
m'étonne pas non plus parce que ça peut
te [ __ ]
c'est dommage que du film vieux garçon
comme ça
m'enfin connais tu passes de touché
c'est comme si j'attendais le résultat
du loto et qu'en même temps grand
l'austère la calandre de leur état
physique
[Musique]